The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GARY GENSLER: All right,
so we're going to try to--
I was giving a little bit
more time for more people
to show up--
chat about what did we
cover this semester.
So I'm going to
try to talk about--
we started out--
money and ledgers,
and why does that matter, and
if you go away from all this.
Satoshi Nakamoto's innovation--
what is that again?
The economics of
blockchain technology,
why the financial sector is
so entwined in all of this,
though it's not the
only place we're going.
A little bit about crypto
finance and public policy
frameworks, and then wrap
it up with a quote from Ben
Franklin-- will be the last
thing we talk about at the end,
about paying it forward.
I don't know how
many people read
the article I wrote
for Coin Desk, which
will run in a day
or two or something,
but that, too, just like helped
me wrap up the whole semester.
As I told you, I'm neither a
maximalist or a minimalist,
but in a few
minutes, I'm probably
going to ask you all to kind of
let me know where you ended up.
So the role of money.
Anybody remember
the role of money
in an economy, the three things?
AUDIENCE: Medium of
exchange, unit of account,
store of value.
GARY GENSLER: Medium of
exchange, unit of account,
store of value.
I don't think we
really know, when
we go through all the history
and the archeology of it,
which came first, but
all three really matter.
So how many people
think that Bitcoin--
just Bitcoin.
I'm not talking about
the other 1,600 tokens--
Bitcoin fulfills these
three roles of money?
James, was that a hand up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yep.
GARY GENSLER: You're saying yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: Alexis?
Oh, we got two.
Hugo?
Somebody take the other side.
Tom?
AUDIENCE: Nope.
GARY GENSLER: That's it?
That's it?
A whole semester, and
all you can say is nope?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Nope?
All right.
Anybody want to give more?
Brotish?
AUDIENCE: So not a store of
value because of [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: So Brotish
says not a store of value,
but isn't it $60 billion
of value right now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So there is a value,
but it's too volatile.
GARY GENSLER: James?
AUDIENCE: I
respectfully disagree.
It's volatile when you think
of it in exchange of a dollar,
but if you move your
mindset, a bitcoin
is a bitcoin is a bitcoin.
Right?
It's only volatile if you
think [INAUDIBLE] a dollar.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, my god.
Here we go.
Ross?
AUDIENCE: But that same
thing is true of corn, right?
A bushel of corn is--
I'm with Brotish on this.
GARY GENSLER: I'm
sorry, were you
in the no camp or the yes camp?
That it's a store of value.
AUDIENCE: I'm in the no camp.
GARY GENSLER: No?
Is it a medium of exchange?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: Oh,
medium of exchange.
Sean?
AUDIENCE: In response
to [INAUDIBLE] none
of the currency can
actually be treated
as a stand alone currency.
Everything has to be
treated as a pair.
So everything's a
relative comparison.
So you can't really treat
Bitcoin on a standalone basis.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
if I agree with that.
But I would say that pretty much
anything can fit into all three
of these buckets.
It just depends on
how dependable it is.
In those three buckets,
with US dollar's
very good at being
medium of exchange,
very good at being a
dependable store of value,
and a steady unit of account.
But you could also have a
bushel of wheat or something.
It would be all three
of these things,
but it wouldn't be equality.
GARY GENSLER: Right, but--
please, Jihee.
AUDIENCE: So the fiat
currency-- the reason why
I think US dollar is
stable is because there
is a US central bank that
actually backs up that.
Because it's just
that fiat currency.
It is a liability
of the central bank,
whereas Bitcoin
doesn't have a center
to worry that banks have.
GARY GENSLER: Nice music
that we're getting.
[INAUDIBLE] a serenade.
AUDIENCE: So therefore,
I don't think
the store of value
argument will work.
GARY GENSLER: So you think--
[INAUDIBLE] saying,
well, there's
no central bank behind it,
so maybe it doesn't hold up.
But if you take anything
away from the class--
and I'm going to have
some other takeaways, too.
Remember, the three things
that about the role of money--
but it's a social construct.
Even with a central bank--
a central bank is, ultimately--
we enshrined in law.
We enshrine it in a big
institution, and bricks,
and mortar, and columns usually.
You always have to
have those columns.
But it's still a
social construct.
And Bitcoin does, in some
ways, have all three of these.
It's just not
broadly acceptable.
It's rarely used as
a unit of account,
but it is sometimes
used as a unit account
in some initial coin offerings.
It's not used, generally,
as a medium of exchange.
But some people are
paid in Bitcoin some.
Software developers are
actually paid in Bitcoin.
And it's $60 billion.
It might be volatile.
It has a store value.
So I'm not trying to take
maximalist or minimalist,
but I'm probably
between Tom and James,
because it does have
all of those qualities
in to some extent in there.
Early money-- remember some
of our walk down memory lane.
Some of these early monies
fell apart, became extinct,
when they got debased.
And we talked about,
early in the semester,
even the story about it.
It was, I think, a British--
when the British got
to the island of Yap,
they went off a couple miles
and quarried the stones
and kept bringing
more yap stones there.
And all of a sudden,
it got debased.
And then, of course, money
turned to paper money.
And in the bottom
left-hand corner,
it started as
warehouse receipts.
So the paper was
just a representation
of the store of value--
the metal, or the corn, or
the wheat that we had earlier.
Another important
thing was ledgers.
Who wants to remind the
class what a ledger is?
Why do ledgers matter?
Anybody want to-- ledgers?
All right, clearly I
didn't make it on ledgers.
Hugo?
AUDIENCE: It's transaction
history, basically.
GARY GENSLER: A store
transaction history.
What else is there?
AUDIENCE: Balances.
GARY GENSLER: Balances of?
AUDIENCE: Accounts.
GARY GENSLER: Accounts.
So it stores a balance
and a transaction.
So you can think of it
as a flow and a balance.
The flow is the transaction--
I give Hugo money.
Regardless of who gives Hugo
money, here's his balance.
So an income statement
and a balance sheet
is a flow and a balance.
But ledgers and keeping ledgers
go back thousands of years.
So blockchain technology
is really about money,
but it's also about a
database that has ledgers.
And ledgers usually
store things of value.
So then we got to fiat currency.
And fiat currency,
as Jihee said,
they were represented by
central bank notes, central bank
reserves, and bank deposits.
So there's three things.
Does anybody want
to see if anybody
listened in those classes?
[LAUGHS] I'm kidding around.
Elan, you're going to say,
why is it those three things?
They're all forms of fiat money.
AUDIENCE: I thought
you were asking
about the illicit
activity in that list.
Is that the question?
GARY GENSLER: All right,
answer the question
you want to answer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE] there
are things that
are important in fiat
currency, or is helpful.
Fiat currency is important
for paying taxes.
And it is allegedly backed
by the social understanding
that the central bank will
respect those notes at the end.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So it's actually--
you're on to this.
It's accepted for taxes.
It's legal tender.
So actually, society
gets together,
through its parliament,
through its executive,
and passes a law that
says it's legal tender.
That gives it a huge leg up.
But this is what
it's really about.
It has huge network effects.
And I wrote this in
the CoinDesk article.
The question I have
for any new currency
is, how does it compete with
those incredible network
effects?
And we talk about Facebook
has incredible network effects
because--
two billion members.
But even money, as a
technology, has a network effect
because people readily accept
it as a unit of account,
a medium of exchange,
a store of value.
And it only loses that
network effect, usually,
when it gets
debased, when people
can't be confident that
it's a good store of value
because somebody else
can mint a lot of it,
or print a lot of it, or a king
starts to print too much of it.
But it has an extraordinary
network effect.
On the other hand,
sometimes currencies
are a little bit challenged,
like the euro right now.
Will the euro ultimately work?
That's for a different class
and a different lecture,
but will the euro
ultimately work long term?
I have my doubts whether it
will work for decades to come,
because there's so
many jurisdictions.
And there's not a
unified fiscal account,
not a unified economy, and not
truly free movement of labor
across that continent.
So that's fiat currency.
It's sort of the game in town
that then Satoshi Nakamoto
is was addressing.
And you all read the
eight-page paper,
but that was the first line.
"Been working on a
new electronic cash
system that's fully
peer-to-peer, with no trusted
third party."
Basically, as Jihee
said, no central bank.
Forget about that central bank.
That was the core
inspiration that was there.
But interestingly, it
wasn't the first try.
And we talked early
in the semester
about at least a handful
of early attempts
that all failed
because they were still
centralized-- like DigiCash
was still very centralized.
Or they couldn't solve
the double spending.
On the internet, you
can send an email twice.
It doesn't need a
central authority.
So what if it gets copied?
But the double spending
is the big issue.
So how did he solve
it, or she solve it?
Does anybody still not know
who Satoshi Nakamoto is?
No?
All right.
I was hoping, I was hoping.
So we talked about
blocks of data
using cryptography
and consensus.
So if you're at a
dinner party, and you
can't remember anything else
from this class, [LAUGHS]
maybe just remember,
oh, yeah, there's
something about blocks of data
using a bunch of cryptography
and consensus.
These slides are on Canvas.
Download this one slide,
you're the expert.
Neha Nerula actually
created this slide,
and I've been using it a lot.
But anybody remember who
invented this whole concept
of blocks of data?
James?
AUDIENCE: Adam someone?
Back?
GARY GENSLER: Adam
Back is a good name,
but he's not the guy
that invented this.
He invented something else,
which was proof-of-work.
Timestamp append-only
logs-- what's
the longest running
blockchain in the world?
AUDIENCE: New York Times?
GARY GENSLER: New York Times.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Crossword.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, here he is.
So two Bell Labs scientists--
this is one of them.
Two Bell Labs scientists
came up with this concept
that you could take a bunch
of data, put it through what's
called a cryptographic
hash function,
and that's a commitment scheme.
You couldn't change it, because
if you changed anything,
the hash function would change.
So what's a cryptographic
hash function?
That's when I use
this idea of you
can take the entire
library of Congress,
and put it into a little
thing called a hash function,
and end up with a
string of characters,
a hexadecimal output.
But a hash function is the key
to what this guy figured out.
And, of course, this.
That's the key.
There was only two
bits of cryptography
in this whole class.
And I know that it seemed like,
oh, why are we teaching this?
But it's this idea that you
can take a whole bunch of data,
put it into this thing
called a hash function,
and it commits to it.
Because if you change
any piece of the data--
any individual
piece-- you're going
to get a different output.
And so it's really the key to
it is that it commits something.
You can do it with the New
York Times crossword puzzle,
and that was just my
observation on it.
So it's about data commitment.
The other thing that
Satoshi Nakamoto used
was asymmetric cryptography,
or digital signatures.
I pulled one of the graphics
that we talked about.
But the idea being that,
long ago, cryptography
was, how do I encrypt
something because I'm
in a military campaign?
And I would, maybe,
just transpose.
The simplest cryptography
from thousands of years
ago was transposing
every letter.
An A becomes a B,
a B becomes a C.
That would be a
transposition of one.
Well, that's pretty hard to
imagine that anybody got away
with that.
But that was early cryptography,
thousands of years ago-- just
simple transposition.
By the mid-20th
century, there was
very complex
transpositions, which
were called keys and enigma.
If you ever go back and watch
that movie Imitation Games,
there was five metal rotors--
they were electronic rotors--
that changed.
And every day, the Germans
would change the five rotors.
But still, they were
symmetric cryptography.
The U boats actually
had the same five rotors
as high command out of--
Berlin, let's say.
So somebody came
along in the 1970s
and said, what if
the key is different?
It's asymmetric.
There's a private
key, and a public key.
The public key, everybody gets,
but the private key, you keep.
And some of those
computer sites--
cryptographers-- are
here, right here, at MIT.
Ron Rivest teaches a
course in cryptography.
But that invention, in
the 1970s, is really key.
So it's hash functions,
and this concept
of a private key
and a public key,
and of course a digital
signature that goes with it.
You probably don't even need to
remember much about this class
about this.
But just know there's
something called
a private key and a public key.
And then, Nakamoto's
real innovation
was off of Adam Back.
And Adam Back said, if I use
some computational work--
if I use computational work
to find a hash function that
has a predetermined
number of zeros,
it's not much of a puzzle.
It's a random number generation.
People will say proof-of-work
is a computational puzzle.
It is simply running--
this thing called mining
is running-- electricity
until you get the right
number of leading zeros.
But it can be
efficiently verified.
So the characteristics of
proof-of-work is of work is--
invented in 1997.
Blockchains were
invented in 1991.
But what Satoshi Nakamoto--
what she did was she pulled that
together after like 20 or 30
failed attempts to have a
digital, non-central money
and said, that that's where
blockchain inspiration is.
And so proof of work--
I use this little visual.
But each block-- do you
remember what the word nonce is?
What's a nonce?
Ross?
Make me proud, somebody.
Can't remember.
AUDIENCE: And once.
GARY GENSLER: What's that?
GARY GENSLER: And
once-- a number once.
AUDIENCE: Number used once.
AUDIENCE: Once.
GARY GENSLER: Number used once.
And so why is a nonce
important for proof of work?
AUDIENCE: Because
it's a unique number.
GARY GENSLER: It's
a unique number.
AUDIENCE: And so
establishing the integrity
of that [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: So all this
whole proof of work--
I'm just going back as a review,
but the whole proof of work
is your computer is
going to randomly keep
picking one thing that changes.
All the data, all the
transactions are the same,
but keep changing this
thing called a nonce
until I get some
leading number of zeros.
And the whole Bitcoin
network around the globe--
all it's really doing is running
a random number generation,
or nonces, until
the hash function
is solved to have 18
leading zeros right now.
Or I should say--
18 leading zeros when Bitcoin's
value was $6,500 a Bitcoin.
It wouldn't surprise
me if it's going
to fall down to 17 leading
zeros, or 16 leading zeros,
because that would
make it easier to find.
All of that cryptography is just
to make the database structure.
This database structure
that is in blockchain--
to make this work.
All that cryptography of hash
functions, digital signatures,
and a little proof
of work is to make it
what's called nearly immutable.
And I'm putting the word
"nearly" in because nothing's
truly immutable.
You could overwhelm even
the Bitcoin network.
Questions about the technology?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Could you just go
over the number of leading zeros
concept again?
GARY GENSLER: So the concept
behind the proof of work
that Adam Back came up with
in the late 1990s was--
gotta run some data
through a hash function.
In his case, in Adam
Back's case, it was emails.
Literally run an email all the
way through a hash function,
and then add an additional
bit of data to it--
this nonce, a number
that's used once--
and run that nonce randomly
until the hash that comes out.
And my little
visual at the bottom
there has some
leading zeros to it.
AUDIENCE: So
beginning of the hash
will be its number of zeros?
GARY GENSLER: Yes.
So in this case,
four leading zeros--
in that little visual there.
All the data that
goes into a block--
in Bitcoin, 1,000 to 1,500
transactions all go in.
They're rolled up in this
thing called a Merkle tree,
but it all goes in.
And the only thing
that's changing
is the miners are trying
to find a random nonce
until the hash has certain
number of leading zeros.
When Nakamoto wrote the paper,
the difficulty was, I think,
10 leading zeros.
And you could solve
that on a laptop.
With eight more leading zeros--
and since it's hexadecimal--
I guess it's 16 to
the eighth power
harder, or something like
seven trillion times harder.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Let's assume
that you and I were trying
to have a transaction today.
And I'm going to
keep some coins.
And I'm [INAUDIBLE]
these for everyone
who's transacting
many, many times
and adding layers of difficulty
to the transaction that we had.
If I want to use my
balance in five years,
how do we know
what my balance is?
I need to go back
through all the history
to know that I have a balance?
GARY GENSLER: So at the heart
of the blockchain technology,
the Bitcoin network, but
also all the other networks,
is the entire transaction
history is public.
This both gives us its
strength, but it's also
one of its challenges.
And so, yes, even
five years from now,
if you want to use
one of your Bitcoins--
which are stored
on the blockchain--
you have to be able to show
that here is a transaction
output from five years ago.
If you remember, there is both
transaction output models--
Bitcoin is a system that keeps
all the individual transactions
in a set called the UTXO--
the Unspent
Transaction Output Set.
You'd have to be able to show
that you have that in 25 years,
you said?
2023-- in 2023, you'd have
to be able to show that.
AUDIENCE: So it's
also a balance.
They all spent this balance
in the transaction [INAUDIBLE]
a record.
GARY GENSLER: It is
a record of an output
from an individual transaction.
So yes, it is like a balance.
But because Bitcoin does not
add up all of those individual--
if you had 13
individual outputs,
the Bitcoin network will
not add up those 13.
You'd have to use each of those
individually as new inputs.
AUDIENCE: And that one is
on the last block, as well.
But I'd have to go
back [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: All right,
so the question is,
does the last block--
Bitcoin has 550-some 1,000
blocks of data right now.
Does the last block
store all of the data?
And the answer is, no, but
it does store a hash function
from the previous block,
which stores a hash function
from the previous block.
So your transaction output might
be on block number 420,000,
130,000 blocks ago.
But what shows that
it's verifiable
is that each one of these blocks
are linked to another block
through this thing called
a commitment scheme
called a hash function.
So technically speaking,
the latest block
has a number in it--
a hexadecimal number,
but a number in it--
called a hash function
that is committed to.
Because all the data
that's come before it--
all the millions of
transactions before it--
if somebody even
changes one of them,
you'll know that
it's been tampered.
AUDIENCE: Let's say I want
to use that balance I have.
Where do the blockchain
verify that I have that?
Is it on the last
block, or does it
go back as long as it
finds the [INAUDIBLE]??
GARY GENSLER: In
essence, it does
both, because the last
block better be valid.
But for you to
spend something, it
has to really go back and find
that the input that you now
want to use is an output
that has not yet been spent.
Eric, did you have something
that you were trying to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it was
a very nice explanation.
You have to go all the way
where your transaction-- where
you got the Bitcoin
was, whatever
block it is [INAUDIBLE]
through the blockchain.
If you would try
to get those coins
and use them as a [INAUDIBLE]
for whatever transaction
you want to do, you have
to go all the way back.
GARY GENSLER: And
this complexity
is part of the
reason why it doesn't
have the same performance--
doesn't have the same
scalability-- yet.
I'm one that believes in a--
I'm optimistic that some
of these scalability
and performance issues
will be overcome.
But it might take three,
five, seven years.
And it's not three
or seven months.
But you're absolutely
right, because you
have to kind of look back--
way back.
The Ethereum network doesn't
just do it on transactions.
It has balances.
And so it's a little bit
more efficient that way,
and has other inefficiencies--
many other big inefficiencies,
but in some ways it--
We talked about smart contracts.
Larry Lessig actually spoke to
us also about smart contracts.
Nick Szabo wrote
about this in 1996.
I like to talk about
the history to say,
it's not all about this one
person that we don't know--
Satoshi Nakamoto--
but a set of promises
specified in digital form,
including protocols, where
parties keep their promises.
Think about it as a
modern way to automate.
So if you're out in
business in the future,
you're thinking about
investing, and somebody
raises a smart contract issue.
Even if you're a
Bitcoin minimalist,
you might say, wait, wait, wait.
There might be some
way I can automate
that which is currently
done by lawyers,
or by back-office
folks, or accountants.
So there's still
something there.
And we talked about a
use case where the SDA--
the Swap Derivatives
Association--
is looking at smart
contracts to try
to automate some of the
previously written mechanisms.
So smart contracts,
which have come out
of this whole blockchain
technology movement,
actually predates
blockchain technology.
But blockchain technology,
again, as well-- maybe we
can do this in a verifiable,
nearly immutable way, as well.
So moving value or
automating some forms
of contractual arrangement.
But remember,
they're not so smart,
and they're not
so much contracts.
You probably still
need the courts,
and there's still some
ambiguity that can't
be pushed into these documents.
So then, we talked a
lot about the economics
of blockchain technology.
And it's around verification
costs and networking costs.
But it's about lowering
verification costs.
And some of those
verification costs
might just be the economic
rents of the current incumbents.
So blockchain technology may
be a really important way
to lower direct verification
costs and deal with censorship.
And I think that was a lot of
what Nakamoto's innovation was
about, was dealing with
censorship that somebody
could deny me the right
to use my money when
I want to use my money.
But it could also be about
lowering economic rents.
Any questions?
And then we said, how do
you assess a use case?
And this was at the core of
even my CoinDesk article.
Before you get to anything
else is, how is it going to be,
really?
It's what's the value
creation proposition?
Again, what are the verification
and networking costs that
are really going to be reduced?
And what are competitors doing?
With a keen eye on--
in trade finance,
there's 20 or 30 efforts,
so it's worthwhile
looking at those 20 or 30.
I don't know which
field you all go into,
but if you're in a field where
nobody has used blockchain
technology, no competitor,
then ask the question,
well, how are competitors
using traditional databases?
And that might be the
opportunity for you.
And it might be a
golden opportunity.
But always look-- what's
the value proposition?
What verification
and networking cost?
What's the competition?
And then, you get into
the sort of tough details.
And if you're
investing, if you're
a venture capitalist
and somebody
can't really tell you why
multiple stakeholders need
to write to the ledger,
and what's their data--
what data are they going to
be storing on this append-only
log--
then I might suggest you
invest in something else.
I mean, you can always
invest in something
because you think that
it's a momentum play.
And if you invest, it's
an early seed investment,
and somebody will bail you out.
But most venture
capitalists-- you're
investing for three to six
years, or three to five years.
And so I wouldn't
always expect somebody
is going to bail you out.
Ask the tough questions.
Jihee?
AUDIENCE: But just because
that is the best solution,
it doesn't mean that they're
going to be successful later,
right?
There are multiple examples
of products, or services,
or [INAUDIBLE] that are
clearly not the best solution
but have taken dominant
position in a market.
So I was curious, should
it be the best solution?
GARY GENSLER: Well, I think
that's one of the questions.
But you're saying, well, what
if it's not the best solution?
Going back to what
Jeff Sprecher said,
can it do something
cheaper, faster, or better?
And it might not be
the best solution.
But if it can at least
answer the question,
is it cheaper,
better, or faster,
you're probably not
going to be successful.
And in some cases, it's
not the best data solution,
but there's such
high economic rents
that however the mortgage
product, the health care
product, the product that
is being delivered now,
the payment solution
that you're saying, ah,
it's not the best solution.
But this is my solution on how
I'm going to do it cheaper,
because they have so
many economic rents.
So maybe that the
word should say,
why is this a better solution,
rather than best solution.
I'll agree with that.
Other queries?
And then, if there's
a native token,
I think that's where
you start to lose May.
But now, I'm going
to ask the class.
How many people have come
out of this semester thinking
there's a lot of
initial coin offerings
that you'd want to
personally invest in?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, is there
anybody in the class
that owns an initial coin
offering-- a non-Bitcoin token?
OK, do you want to tell us why?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: Give us the value
proposition, or the pitch.
AUDIENCE: So I went to work
for a startup, [INAUDIBLE]
this summer.
And after the summer,
they paid me US dollars.
But after the summer, they gave
me a lot of tokens they have.
And I saved a
little bit of them.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So you got paid in tokens.
AUDIENCE: No, I was
paid in US dollars.
After the summer, they
gave me most of the--
like a bunch of--
some of the tokens.
GARY GENSLER: As a bonus or?
AUDIENCE: As a bonus, yeah.
GARY GENSLER: I see.
As a bonus, you got--
all right.
And you sold some of them?
AUDIENCE: Some of
them, sold them.
GARY GENSLER: And I see.
AUDIENCE: Some of them
I still [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: All right.
And do you think that there's
a use for these native tokens?
AUDIENCE: This specific startup?
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
Names will not be repeated.
It's being filmed.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
GARY GENSLER: I don't know.
Sean.
AUDIENCE: So I
thought of it-- well,
I just thought a little
of like Tron, which is a--
GARY GENSLER: Tron.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's a gaming.
GARY GENSLER: Gaming site.
AUDIENCE: Which is a--
basically a company
started by a friend of mine.
So it's kind of a
token of support
instead of like [INAUDIBLE].
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So you bought some tokens
as a token of support
for a friend, who
started a company.
Do you think they have some use?
Can you use the token?
AUDIENCE: I don't
think there's-- well--
[LAUGHTER]
Well, it's supposed to be the--
building up to the biggest
gaming network [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: But is
it pre-functional,
or is it functional?
It's pre-functional.
Hugo?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GARY GENSLER: You
have-- you are?
AUDIENCE: I have-- yeah.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
You don't-- all right.
He's got a whole portfolio.
I can tell.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I've been interested in
this for over a year now.
So I wanted to make
a whole radical
of like, oh, this one looks
like it's going to go well,
but this one's a scam.
And there are some that seem
like sure-- in the long run,
they may retain some value.
But I probably made
some bad investments.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So I don't want to make you sort
of grieve those bad investment
decisions, but are any of
your tokens that you have held
or hold currently-- are
any of them functional?
Like, they can be
used on a network?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I actually use
at least one of them.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
Here.
Are you an owner, or
you've got a question?
AUDIENCE: I'm an
owner, but not--
I haven't voted.
Both the tokens-- I'm
mining the tokens.
But in any case, I
wouldn't disregard maybe
tokens that's a valid way of
generating a means to jumpstart
a network and create
some sort of valid way
to drive collective action for
some disintermediation effort,
because I mean I--
and I think it's a
little bit unfair
to ask if we kind of
join or support ICOs
in the context of there's
huge amount of scams
that are [INAUDIBLE]
right now in the media.
But I wouldn't disregard the
whole concept of tokens here.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE].
I admit it might have
been an unfair question.
I was just trying to get--
I was just trying to get some
support in the room for tokens.
AUDIENCE: The concept for
me is absolutely valid.
I would explore,
seriously explore--
if I launch a startup
in the blockchain space,
seriously explore
the possibility
of using maybe tokens in the
permissionless environment.
So I suppose the permission--
GARY GENSLER: So I think
that there is definitely
a future in this overall
technology of making
a database harder
to tamper with,
more immutable on
a scale, maybe not
100% immutable, but
closer to that immutable
and inverifiable.
I think that native tokens
could help jump start a network.
What I think the challenge
is I think the challenge is,
how do you compete
with fiat currency
that has such extraordinary
network effects?
So the Ernst & Young study,
the recent study, I think
captures this a bit when they
looked at the 140 largest ICOs
from 2017.
Only about I think
it was 17 of 140
have a functioning
network right now,
where you can use
the token, 13%.
But of those 17, I
think seven of them,
the networks that are
live, instead of, well,
guess what, we'll also take
fiat currency for this service
that we're providing,
whether they're providing
file storage or something else.
So they definitely
used a native token
to jumpstart the network
as a crowdfunding,
but then when they got to
the later functional stage,
the operator, the
entrepreneur says,
I don't want to limit my users.
I'm going to also take fiat
currency to buy or secure
whatever service I'm having.
And I think that's the
business model challenge.
And it may well be that
there are networks,
just like in gaming sites,
where you want skins or shields,
and there's something about
only trading those tokens.
But to date, that's
been a limited class.
That's where I probably
will declare myself.
I think, of course, there's
a bunch of tradeoffs
over the next three
to seven years
that will be sorted out around
performance, privacy, security.
We talked about layer 2.
If any of you are actually
interested in work
in the blockchain
technology field,
you're going to learn a
lot about layer 2 solutions
and side chains and all the
performance scalability things
that colleagues over at the
Digital Currency Initiative
are spending a lot of time
on this question right here.
And then, of course,
this is a business model.
Just purely as a
venture capitalist,
you have to think about,
how do I get adoption?
How do-- what's my
customer user interface?
I'm sure, Iman, you're thinking
a lot about this, right?
You could have the best
idea on a data structure.
You could have a really
nifty idea on a native token.
But you still have
to deal with whatever
venture capitalist has to do is,
how do I get users to use this?
Adoption.
What's my UI?
And it's sort of a much
more generic set of issues.
Iman.
AUDIENCE: That was
my answer to Jihee.
She's totally right.
It's all about-- it's a tension
between adoption and quality
of product.
And that's why we
moved from Ethereum
to the public blockchain.
But we didn't think that
it will be mass adopt by--
massively adopted
by the incumbents.
So we moved to a
permission blockchain
because of the adoption.
GARY GENSLER: And I can't
remember if you're able to say.
Which are you using--
Hyperledger Fabric or Corda or?
AUDIENCE: We're using Corda
because of the state channels
solution that they provide.
GARY GENSLER: So we
talked about frameworks.
Over time, it's my thought that
that orange line, the slope
of that will come down,
and we'll move more
towards the decentralized side.
But for the orange line, the
slope to come down, in essence,
the costs of the scalability,
security, even the coordination
needs to come down.
It's always going to be some
challenge on governance.
In essence, who is going
to pay for the software
development in a truly
decentralized network?
And Bitcoin has been supported,
for instance, by, really,
an incredible group of
Bitcoin Core developers,
in part because
they just believe
in it, in part that
some are funded
by institutions like MIT.
But it's still-- it's always
a challenge in a truly
decentralized space.
Who's going to fund--
who's got the economic interest
to fund the continued updates
and software?
I think Uber could be completely
a decentralized network.
And probably, drivers
would get paid more.
But then where would
be the incentive?
Who would work on the
software development
to update their ride app?
So there's a key tradeoff there.
The financial sector--
well, it moves and allocates
money and risk.
We talked about that.
But it relies on a
system of ledgers,
and it's always had a symbiotic
relationship with technology.
The opportunities-- these
are the key opportunities,
which I think any
thought fintech--
it's not just blockchain but
even AI and machine learning--
has around finances.
The customer
interfaces-- there's
a lot of legacy
customer interfaces
that you can actually
compete with,
if you're doing a startup.
The economic rents are high.
There's 7 and 1/2 percent
of the economy is finance.
Not all of the 7 and
1/2 percent is rents,
but there is a lot of extra--
excuse the expression-- a
lot of extra vig or juice
in that model.
And, of course, we've
had repeated crises
and instability.
And financial inclusion--
we talked about products
like Alipay and M-Pesa
that were really
about financial inclusion
using new technologies.
So what are the
technologies in our time?
I just put up a nice
little graphic here.
I'm doing some work
with a group called
FinTech at CSAIL, the Computer
Science and AI Lab here.
And when we leave with
the funding companies,
the big funding companies
of that unit over there,
blockchain is on their list,
but it's not number one.
To just put it in context, in
terms of their technologies,
they're thinking
about machine learning
and AI would probably
be the biggest piece.
But just to give a flavor for--
but it's one of the
top three or four.
But as we've talked about,
they have challenges.
The financial sector
sees a lot of challenges.
AUDIENCE: I just want to
go back to previous slides,
and how would the virtual
reality impact finance?
I'm not sure.
[INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: That
has happened--
AUDIENCE: AR and VR,
[INAUDIBLE] tech, finance.
GARY GENSLER: I'm not
familiar with the projects
in that space.
But where-- and I'm
sure I'm getting now,
you're going to inspire
me to do some research
in the next day or two to shoot
your email with some projects.
But virtual reality
and hearing it does
allow for more
financial inclusion.
And the question really
is, can you just, rather--
think of the user experience.
If you can find an enjoyable
way to spend more money
through virtual reality,
the banking system
wants to tap into that.
It's not one of the top
things at FinTech at CSAIL,
I'd say AI, machine learning,
biometrics, and blockchain.
Everything's in the
cloud, so they're not
asking, right now, MIT to
help them with cloud issues.
Open API is a really big
issue, particularly in London
and in the UK, where it's been
regulated that the banks need
to use Open API.
So I'd say AR and
virtual reality
is probably eighth
on the list there.
And I just include it,
because I kind of think it's--
they'll find a way to
change a user interface.
We talked about there's
a bunch of issues,
and that's really
leading to the use.
We talked about traditional
databases, which--
where parties can just
create, read, write,
the ledger, the private
blockchain, which,
of course, is what most of
trade finance, most of payments,
all the big central banks
that have looked at it
or moved from Ethereum to
doing Hyperledger projects--
Singapore and Canada's Jasper--
and maybe permissionless.
But the finance is really in
the second bucket right now.
Eric, it's not to say that
native tokens won't take off
and, Hugo, that your portfolio
will be worth something, maybe.
So here, we went through
a bunch of use cases.
But the biggest use case so far
has been the $20 to $30 billion
that's been raised through ICOs.
I personally think that's
going to come down, way down.
But payment systems--
I mean we might differ on
the views of XRP, a token,
but Ripple and
other companies have
done a lot to try to be a
catalyst for change and payment
systems.
We talked a lot
about trade finance.
Again, they're more
in the permissions
than the permissionless.
Clearing and settling--
what's going on in Australia.
Again, permissionless, not--
I mean permissioned, not
permissionless.
And then some of
the non-financial--
had a lively discussion about
supply chain management,
and James, I'll forever remember
that you're not a fan of it.
But Walmart and Cargo
might disagree with James.
And they have active
projects on it.
And Lauren gave--
where's Lauren?
She's here, maybe--
gave a reason why
in supply chain
sustainability that you
might be on the other side.
Digital ID was the last
thing we talked about.
So there's a lot going on, and
when there's $20 or $30 billion
raised, there's going
to be-- these projects
will have some life to them.
We'll learn a lot from
them along the way.
Crypto finance-- when I
first put this slide up,
it wasn't $110 billion.
And gosh knows I
did this yesterday,
so I don't even know
what it is today.
Pretty volatile market.
Interestingly, Bitcoin staggered
about 55% or 57% of the market.
So there's a high correlation,
though Ethereum slid, and XRP
is number two in that market
since we first got together
in September.
Here, what I think the
challenge is, as an investor--
I'm not trying to pick on
you, Hugo, but you know,
an investor.
But I think that's the
number one challenge.
I really do.
What's the viability
of that token?
And Eric, I'll agree with you.
Some tokens will
be worth something.
But it's assessing that.
But the markets are readily
susceptible to fraud.
How do I keep custody
for the private key?
Fidelity has announced
they're going
to have a new
private key solution,
so it's interesting that big
incumbents are coming in.
It's not just the Zappos and the
early stage custody solutions.
Even Backed, the
Intercontinental Exchange,
has put a lot of money into it.
And they'll, in essence,
have a custody solution,
because you could buy
Bitcoin, one day futures,
have a Bitcoin, and then
they would, in essence,
hold custody for you.
And then we talked
about crypto exchanges.
And the key thing-- and
if you take anything away
about exchanges, other than
right now they're unregulated
and they're probably highly
susceptible to front running
and manipulation, is that
they're a little bit different,
because they're
not just matching
agents, which the London Stock
Exchange or the New York Stock
Exchange are [INAUDIBLE],, but
they also are counterparties
and custodians.
The other thing to take
away about crypto exchanges
is they're highly centralized.
So it's a central irony that
Satoshi Nakamoto is trying
to have decentralization,
and yet there's
an awful lot of centralization.
So I'm just thinking
about core takeaways.
If you're ever investing, or
you're thinking about this,
or you're just involved in
a dinner party conversation,
that central irony in
a decentralized space,
95% of the real transactions are
happening on crypto exchanges.
My thought about
crypto exchanges--
they'll not be 200 of them
that much longer either.
We talked about
Initial Coin Offerings.
Central takeaway is they're
fundraising vehicles.
Whether you believe
in or not believe
in the US and Canadian
approach under the Howey Test,
but they help build a network,
raise money in anticipation
the tokens are issued
before it's functional.
I think the latest
study was that--
what was it-- 1 and 1/2 percent
are actually functional,
and 98 and 1/2 percent
are issued pre-functional.
So that's not a problem.
It's just-- that's the--
means it's probably an
investment vehicle, not
a utility token.
And that whole thing
about utility token
versus security tokens, it
stretched pretty darn thin.
We talked about public
policy frameworks,
guarding against illicit
activity, financial stability,
investing public.
My overall thought on this--
and I accept that others
will have other views--
is that any new technology, if
it grows to be economy-wide,
needs to live within
public policy frameworks,
or society will change those
public policy frameworks
modestly.
But you still want
to protect the public
against core social goods.
It happened when the
railroad came along.
It happened when telegram came
along in the 19th century.
It happened with the internet.
Societies don't
have technologies
fully outside of whatever
social fabric we want to create.
And we do that
social fabric stuff
through politics and parliaments
and executives and regulators.
But we don't leave big parts
of our economy outside of it.
This stuff is still small.
It's $100 billion.
The worldwide capital markets
are over $300 trillion.
But it's gained a lot
of public attention.
And particularly, we want to
guard against illicit activity.
Most folks do.
Maybe not everybody.
But most do.
No, I recognize.
Hopefully, you all do.
Well, I don't know.
So we talked about the US
Securities Law, the Howey Test.
It's not-- if you forget the
Howey Test, it's totally fine.
But it's core to these
initial coin offerings,
and it was that four-part test--
investment of money in
a common enterprise,
expectation of profits.
So if you get into
some debate, and you
want to have some
fun with somebody,
you can say you
know the Howey Test.
But it's really more this.
I prefer the Duck Test.
Just use common sense.
This course has been more
about critical reasoning skills
than anything.
So if somebody's trying to sell
you something or hustle you
on something, and you are
now a venture capitalist,
and you're investing,
use the Duck Test.
You can even remember
the Duck Test
about whether they're trying
to sell you something,
and it has nothing
to do with the law.
It just-- so where do I think
crypto exchanges will go?
I think that they'll have to
fix this whole custodial duty
stuff.
They might all use
Fidelity's product.
Or they'll keep it
in-house or spin it off.
I think they'll have to start
complying with any money
laundering.
We saw one study that said
a quarter of all exchanges
don't even have any AML.
I think two years from
now, that will be way down.
I think margins
will compress, and I
don't think there'll
be 200 exchanges
two or three years from now.
There'll be five or
10 relevant exchanges
at some point in time.
On Initial Coin
Offerings, I think
we're going to keep seeing
a high failure rate.
There's still about 200 a
month, but there'll probably
be fewer of them.
I think that there's going to
be a lot of enforcement actions.
Occasionally, you'll
see something--
the Securities and Exchange
Commission or some other--
maybe it will be in
Japan or elsewhere will
be bringing more cases.
And what will be interesting
in 2019 is to watch,
does any of the
big ones go live?
And I think this
will be a real test.
Does Filecoin figure
out what to do?
They raised a quarter
of a billion dollars.
Telegram raised $1.7 billion.
Do they figure out
what to do and make
a real live effort in 2019?
And it will test the economics.
And by the way, Eric,
it might pull me more
towards where you are, right?
I mean Telegram's-- they got a
lot of smart folks over there
working on this.
And by the way, Facebook
has advertisements out
hiring people on
blockchain technology.
So there's a lot of very
big tech companies hiring
and recruiting in this space.
But I think 2019 will be
interesting to see, what does--
what is Telegram?
What is Filecoin?
What do some of the big,
hopefully, well-meaning
companies do with these tokens?
Central banks-- mostly
in the monitor phase.
But I'd say the thing
to watch is Sweden.
It'll be really
interesting what they
do with their E-krona project.
Do they go live and say,
inspired by blockchain?
The E-krona project is
not blockchain technology,
but it's completely inspired by
Satoshi Nakamoto saying, well,
we, the central bank, Jihee's
the central bank says,
we're going to do what
Satoshi Nakamoto's--
we're going to have a
central bank digital token.
You can use it at Starbucks.
You can use it wherever.
I'd watch that.
I think Venezuela will
probably fail on the other end.
But it'll be interesting.
There might be some distressed
country that does something.
So how would I conclude?
I think blockchain does--
this is my disclosure.
I think it does provide a
real peer-to-peer alternative.
I think it's a legit
live application.
It might not be the best, but
is it better than some others?
Is it something you could use?
Verification and
networking cost--
I'm going to repeat on that--
is the key.
But you always, I think,
have to assess, is it
the right use case?
Is this use case
But as we've talked,
I think there
are real use cases
more in permissioned
than permissionless.
Remember anything.
Money is just-- we all
humans, the 7 billion
of us that live now,
have to thank somebody
about 10,000 years ago, but came
up with this technology called
money.
Store value, medium
of exchange, unit
of account-- it's just a
social construct, which
is a reason why I say, we
could have a social construct
that is decentralized money.
I absolutely believe
we could have that.
But we'd all have to accept it.
Where I have less
optimism is that you'd
want to accept it for a
closed, bounded ecosystem
only for file storage.
That's where I'm a
little challenged as to,
what is the real
economics of that?
Financial sector's
characteristics
and challenges--
is it good?
It's fertile ground, because
finance is built on ledgers.
And finance is big--
7 and 1/2 percent
of our economy.
And around the globe,
it's anywhere from 5%
to probably 8% of
those economies.
Most other countries,
it's less than the US,
but it's still-- it's big.
Incumbents are,
of course, looking
at permissioned blockchains.
And unfortunately,
crypto finance
has a bunch of scams and frauds.
And that hurts the development.
But I think adoption
will come, but it
rests on solving a bunch
of technical issues,
like the Digital Currency
Initiative's trying to solve.
What are the commercial use
cases and the public policy?
I wouldn't lead
with public policy.
I don't think that's
the main issue here.
But if this is ever
going to be anything,
it's got to get over that.
So mostly, it's probably going
to be a catalyst for change,
more than actual real thoughts.
Questions?
Thoughts?
Eric.
AUDIENCE: On the
third point, I--
GARY GENSLER: Use
cases must address why
versus a traditional database.
AUDIENCE: I always
had the feeling
that it seemed the
permissioned space, where
you have the most or the
biggest urge to prove where--
if your submission needs a
blockchain solution as opposed
to a traditional--
I mean making a case against
the centralized database
is kind of easy, versus
a distributed database.
I think it's a little bit tough.
But in the
permissionless space, I
think you don't have
to struggle much,
because it's absolutely
justified that you can--
because you're dealing with a
decentralized configuration,
where there's no one in
charge of guaranteeing
that we have a--
GARY GENSLER: So Eric's
raising the question,
why not use a
traditional database?
Why ever use a permissioned--
AUDIENCE: In the
permissioned space,
because permissionless
is perfectly justified.
But in the
permissioned space, I'm
not saying it's not justified.
The point is being
that in our project,
we argued for a
permissioned system.
We made some justifications
in that space,
so the point is that I just
wanted to get your thoughts so
that in the
permissionless spaces,
you don't have to
struggle much in that.
GARY GENSLER: Permissionless
blockchain technology,
looking forward a
number of years,
looking forward to when some of
the scalability and performance
gets better, can give
you verification costs.
And it's censorship-resistant
or practically
censorship-resistant, unless
somebody does a 51% attack.
But so I think that the truly
decentralized distributed
permissionless system has
a lot of-- a lot to offer.
But it comes with a lot of
costs, too, and challenges--
hard to do the governance and
hard to get coordinated action.
And as you've heard
me say, I think
there's only probably going
to be a very limited use
cases for native tokens,
native product-specific tokens
like a Filecoin or a restaurant
review coin or a health care
coin.
I have-- I have my
doubts about that.
An economy-wide coin, a
cryptocurrency like Bitcoin--
I think there's more
use, particularly
if you have a weak central
bank, a weak fiscal policy.
A country like Venezuela in the
future might adopt something.
I think there's a lot to
be said for permissionless,
but permissioned systems versus
traditional databases, I think,
also gives something.
And I'll use the Australian
stock exchange for one,
but they know their customers.
They know they have--
I think the number
was 77 members.
They can take their database
and decentralize it and put it
on all 77 member companies,
if that's the right number,
and say, you're
now sharing that.
And so then there's no
single point of failure,
and we can lower what's
called reconciliation costs,
because you all needed
some of that data anyway.
The historic data-keeping,
the historic nature of it
came up with each
of those 77 members
having individual databases.
So I could see that there is
a real benefit in probably
efficiency and
lowering costs, which
means lowering costs
of verification,
lowering networking
costs, because there's
77 members, trade finance.
I could see some
of that as well.
So that-- but you
might be right.
Oracle might be
able to just adopt
that in a traditional database.
Sabrina.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
it seems like you're
describing that they have some
form of distributed consensus.
And that's the
main reason, right?
But there's--
GARY GENSLER: And
distributed the data
stored on multiple nodes,
because it's multiple copies
of the same data.
AUDIENCE: Right, but yeah.
There's-- I mean if that still
can be implemented without
watching.
I'm playing the Aleem
today, since he's not here.
But there's no--
GARY GENSLER: No, but we--
AUDIENCE: That's been a long
solved problem of how consensus
algorithms that--
or you can replicate
state on the same state
on both the machines
and tolerate some [INAUDIBLE]
number of failures.
So I personally don't really
see the use of blockchain
in permissioned systems, but
I do see a lot of potential
for permissionless systems,
just because those algorithms
already exist out there
to do [INAUDIBLE]..
GARY GENSLER: So what
Sabrina's raising--
you can take the Sabrina seat.
You're-- Sabrina's a master's
student at computer science
at MIT, so she probably knows
what she's talking about--
is really saying, well,
you can do a lot of that.
You can have
distributed databases
without blockchain technology.
You can have-- and
there's ways that
this Byzantine-fought
tolerance has been addressed
in distributed
databases that you don't
need blockchain technology.
The concept of a block,
commitment hash, block,
a commitment hash,
block technology.
And I accept that.
But I'm not going
to accept it to say
that there's no space for
permissioned blockchain
technology.
What there is space
for is the 80 of you
in this room to have different
opinions on all of this.
You want to close out?
I want to-- I have one
more slide I want to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GARY GENSLER: So this is,
of course, about money,
so I went back and found a
quote from Benjamin Franklin
that I like.
And to me, it's about a concept
that I hope you all live by.
It's paying it forward.
Paying forward is partly
because all of us in this room
are privileged.
We're at MIT or Harvard or
Wellesley, but we're at MIT.
And so what did
Ben Franklin say?
And it does close on money.
"I do not pretend
to give such a deed.
I only lend it to you.
When you meet another honest
man in similar distress,
you must pay me by
lending this sum to him
and joining him to discharge
the debt by a like operation,"
paying it forward, basically.
"He should be able and shall
meet another opportunity,
I hope, that this may,
though many hands."
So Benjamin Franklin,
over 200 years ago,
he closes, this
is a trick of mine
of doing a deal good
with a little money.